[Music]
gas prices are still soaring across the
country
aaa says the average price for a gallon
of regular is now more than four dollars
and 25 cents and with prices that high
we're all looking for a little relief
chris van cleave has an idea he's riding
through dallas with some ideas and some
advice on how to get the most out of
every gallon good morning chris
good morning the key is gentle gentle
acceleration gentle braking we spent the
day with an expert that automakers go to
to see how far you can stretch a tank of
gas and even in this giant suv we're
beating the epa estimate which means
we're getting more bang for our buck so
buckle up because we're going for a ride
in the slow lane
why burn fuel if you don't have to that
is wayne gerdes gospel especially
driving in southern california home to
the nation's highest gas prices coming
in about two bucks a gallon more than a
year ago are you really getting 87 miles
to the gallon yeah i'm getting well over
80 miles per gallon
[Music]
curtis is a world class hypermiler
someone who goes to great lengths to
stretch their fuel economy he's managing
about 60 percent more miles than the epa
says his plug-in prius hybrid should be
getting
this is very much a slow and steady
approach to driving yeah you've hit it
with that wayne always follows the speed
limit even on the freeway this road
right here is 55 miles per hour what
does 55 miles per hour mean to you
means you're going a lot slower than
everybody else on the road
that's okay they're not buying my gas
the faster you go the more fuel you burn
speed kills fuel economy there's no way
around it and little things add up i
notice we're not using the air
conditioning i'll run air conditioning
when it gets above 80. i said it like 76
to 78 degrees
because i want to just be comfortable
some hypermilers make their cars more
aerodynamic or drive behind semis to
reduce wind resistance wayne sticks to
the slow lane and follows all traffic
laws the optics can be bad to other
drivers
[Music]
because it's not the normal pattern that
we all follow most of the tips in the
hyper milers playbook are smart and
they're things we should have been
taught back in driver training now what
just happened here
you never came to a stop bingo bingo
bingo gerdes goal always stay moving
gently accelerating and he starts slowly
breaking well before a red light so he
can cruise through it as it turns green
during our drive around town he averaged
110 miles per gallon on city streets
red light boom back off yellow yellow
yellow start breaking way back here
he put me behind the wheel of this
souped-up audi
i'm getting passed by a lot of cars here
but slow and steady upped our efficiency
by a third you don't need to race just
nice and easy up we go this is very
different wayne's cut his fuel
consumption about forty percent saving
him about twenty five hundred dollars a
year
every dollar i save in fuel is dollar in
my pocket
now wayne drives for a living so he
spends a lot more time on the road than
most people but some things that you can
do if you've got a ski rack up here on
the car that you're not using take it
off that'll slow you down also aaa tells
you this all the time make sure your
tires are properly inflated under
inflated tires will cost you miles per
gallon but guys let's talk about the
junk in the trunk all the stuff that
we're driving around with can weigh as
much as another person that you're
taking everywhere you go
that will also cost you fuel efficiency
tony
chris i was hoping you would talk about
the junk in the trunk no ski rack
light luggage 78 on the ac and you're in
the slow lane are you going to be doing
this you can be following curtis's
advice
we did it all morning
it works
it's just hot
he didn't answer that question okay
we hear you chris i hear you
i don't like getting passed on the
highway i know i see you
guys thank you that was a great piece
definitely a talker really good that's
cool
some people were those truckers waving
to him or were they when they were
honking yeah i don't know if they were
talking about that friendly yeah i might
you all be doing that i don't think so
you know it takes you got to be a really
well planned out individual to get on
the road and then go 55 you know the
exact speed limit exactly and you know i
got the three kids there's a lot of
sports so we got a lot of junk in the
trunk and i'm not talking about some mix
a lot but somebody watched that piece
and they said i'm going to try that i'm
guessing i like i like curtis a lot i'm
guessing that that is not the first time
he's explained all this
that's right he's he's talk to you about
it if you see him that's right